ja hi Christoph hi budy Ogün und alle
Leute die das Video gucken hi ich habe
verschiedene Fragen an dich Buddy und
zwar als allererstes wann hast du damit
angefangen deine Persönlichkeiten deine
multiplen Persönlichkeiten zu
entwickeln die zweite ist welches ist
deine lieblingspersönlichkeit wenn du
eine hast und die dritte ist momentan
wird ja viel über Integration debattiert
und meine Frage wä dann an dich als
jemand mit verschiedenen Charakteren aus
verschiedenen na ja
Hintergründen was sagst du zum Thema
Integration wie sollten wir dieses Thema
angehen oder sollten wir es überhaupt
diskutieren bis ja Josi ich grüße dich
mein Freund ja erste Frage wie der
Nacken auf die Sachen kommt weiß ich
nicht der ist Hor und crazy s ich da
kommt so einiges
raus ja no com von meiner Seite kann ich
schwer beantworten aber seit wan das war
weiß do das war weiß ich habe ihn ja
kennengelt ich habe ihn kennengelernt
vor vier Jahren in Thailand da hat er
mich auch schon vollgesüzt mit sein
ganzen Telefon Geschichten und so also
das ist das hat ich da auch schon
gemerkt gehabt dass er ein bisschen
nicht ganz dicht in der Berne drinne ist
ja welche er am liebsten spielt ich weiß
dass er abends immer vom Spiegel steht
und Kim Jong
nachmacht Prinz Charles macht auch
manchmal nach also der scheint so
Vorlieben zu sein dritte Frage ja
Integration ich sag da nur eins wir
fassen uns alle an die Hand und machen
eine riesige Party wo ist das Problem ne
Christop ja eben wo ist das Problem ob
ich jetzt gelb rot oder schwarz bin oder
gelbrot schwarz oder grün einfach in Arm
nehmen und
tanzenig